we're going to assume you want to hear
some spoilery lines from spider-man no
way home but how do these snippets of
dialogue tie into past mcu movies and
how do they reveal precious details
about spider-man's inevitable
reinvention
for as long as there has been a
spider-man there has been a kid having
difficulty as youtube influencers would
say monetizing his craft in the comics
he's been a wrestler a photographer a
teacher and more and far from home he's
a student and by the end he's
essentially out on the street forced to
start anew in a cruddy depressing
nondescript apartment spider-man's name
is peter parker
it's an interesting dynamic and no way
home that holland's peter parker goes
from being quote the most famous person
in the world to someone who literally
has no one left who knows he's alive
but whether he's famous or anonymous the
one constant is that peter barely has
two pennies to rub together not that
this matters to mj her coffee shop job
likely isn't bringing in big bucks
either but with their big brains and
mj's mit education imminent better days
might be ahead with any luck those days
might just be together
this is a key sentence but one quickly
tossed off by doctor strange as an
explanation for why he and peter can't
simply jump through time allah endgame
fixing reality to suit their needs the
green time stone obviously is one of the
six infinity stones it was contained in
the eye of agamotto for many of
strange's early adventures empowering
him in moments like his now legendary
negotiations with dormammu say it with
us
i've come to bargain
doctor strange handed over the stone in
exchange for iron man's life and thanos
would later use the time stone to bring
vision back to life just long enough to
get his mind stoned it was later
destroyed but the avengers time heist
had hulk convincing the ancient one to
give up the stone in 2012 after the
world was saved the time stone was
returned by captain america for all
intents and purposes our doctor strange
does not have the time stone
asked by toby mcguire's spider-man the
question is one of many that shines a
light on what does and does not exist in
the ultimate universes these spider-men
come from such questions also work on a
second level as perhaps a bit of
jealousy that tom holland came of age
when the entirety of the marvel toy box
was available to play with not the
restrictive stick to your own studio
mindset when mcguire and andrew garfield
were headlining the franchise in no way
home holland's peter parker cites his
avengers inclusion as proof that he's a
team player this is interesting because
in most ways the other two spider-men
seem to be better experienced and more
capable but sure enough when holland's
parker draws up a plan the other two
fall in line behind him perhaps sensing
a more authoritative battle-worn
presence
this is an interesting sentence because
of our memory of the infinity war
trailers when they made it look as if
hulk was going to be fighting in wakanda
of course they then pulled a switcheroo
with banner in the hulkbuster the no way
home trailers avoid this phrase in an
effort to make it seem as if dr
strange's librarian slash assistant
slash confidante wong is opposed to the
whole make the world forget who
spider-man is spell which in actuality
he's just turning a blind eye to it huge
difference essentially walking away from
the problem wong leaves strange and
pizza to deal with it themselves from
there things don't go so well showing
that wong did indeed know best although
to be fair he really should have
protested as emphatically as the
trailers made it look like he would
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
during a tense moment in the film when
peter has taken all the villains back to
happy hogan spiritual oasis to devise a
plan electro asks this question of tom
holland's peter parker but although he
seeks to belittle our hero what electro
doesn't realize is that those legos
symbolize a lot more than mere playtime
in spider-man homecoming that death
style lego set is what brings peter and
ned together for endless hours of team
bonding join me in together we'll build
my new lego death star
ned uses the emperor to approach pizza
in one scene and later when ned sees
pizza spider walking across the ceiling
he drops the death star
[Music]
[Applause]
no way home turns the death star into a
call back to those original moments of
friendly bonding as the set is destroyed
once again and lays in rubble for most
of the film but as a sleep reminder of
their friendship at the end of the movie
when ned's memory of pete has been wiped
along with everyone else on the planet
one of the first items peter places in
his crummy new apartment is that lego
minifigure of the emperor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]